growing up under apartheid then a life  built on lies and indifference but  unless we  privileged white lives and did something  our words were meaningless you are  sentenced imprisonment for 12 years we  are prisoners of conscience or were  prisoners of war so they've been  attempts some go a little summer little  mount but no one go out always the first  time you need to get out of here  everybody comes in here like I'm gonna  break out of here by next week if you're  having a plan I join you  we've got something we make keys from  would total crazy search Lots comes  every and should be or Wars becomes is  nothing they'd like water into potholes  into you there is something and I would  find  [Music]  thank you my bad so then my dad again  why won't you come  [Music]  is it glutton luck we can make a key  file get 25 years if you're lucky I'll  hold it in their head of you not  [Music]  not running away it's like what this is  how we fight  now  what is this  [Music]  you